good afternoon okay I know I've got the
last slot of the day and I know
everyone's desperate to go and have a
drink or go and get ready for the boat
cruise but please bear with me for a
little bit I promise I will try not to
bore you there's only so much coffee and
beer that someone can actually have
before they start to get a little sleepy
and I would like to start feeling those
effects very soon so this is a talk
called introduction to chaos engineer
anyone know the term chaos engineering a
few people perfect so my name is Paul
stack you can find me pretty much
anywhere on the internet like Twitter
Facebook is to get all at least the cool
kid sites at stack 72 and I work for a
company called giant ok joint is a small
cloud provider and it is a company
that's owned by Samsung so we do a lot
of work with Samsung anyone class
themselves as a distributed systems
engineer yeah I can see some people
nodding okay we are now in the era of
creating what we call distributed
systems and distributed systems have
become very difficult and interesting to
maintain and this is actually a diagram
from app dynamics it's a it's an APM
tool and it will actually monitor the
tracing through your entire system if
you instrument it correctly and you can
see the different pieces that each
application talks to and so on and so
forth what this signifies is that life
is becoming very difficult no longer can
we clone a single repository excuse me
usually we can't go to a company and
clone a single repository and have
everything running on your dev laptop
because you have databases you have
security systems you have all sorts of
you know multiple applications that talk
to each other different runtimes
different languages etc etc and it's
becoming very very very difficult in
order to actually test
can anybody realistically tell me that
what they test locally on their
development machine is actually what is
in production absolutely not it's it's
becoming more and more difficult I used
to work for a company in America and I
will never forget when the CTO
he said we're not in the era where you
can split your application you were
gonna go micro-services you can choose
whatever language that you want in order
to do it and if you build it you run it
at the end of the two years experiment
that I will call it an experiment we had
a hundred and twelve different services
and we actually had nine different
languages in production one of them was
actually one of the apps was written in
closure and there was only one developer
in the entire company who understood
closure and of course that developer
left so we have this application to
manage and it became an absolute
nightmare
so distributed systems are really
becoming everywhere and there's so many
parts that are disconnected that you
need to understand what's happening real
Bev's don't test in development anymore
I I say that jokingly but at the same
time I actually say it truthfully as
well we are becoming much more confident
that when we test code in production
then it's actually starting to be
correct because of the tools and and and
the monitoring and all that we actually
do but the question is how do we build a
complex distributed system and be able
to scale it this is a conundrum an IT
right now this is really difficult and
not everyone's getting it right I'm
seeing so many blog posts these days of
saying I'm going from a monolith to
microservice I'm sure we've all read
these and now we're starting to see some
blog posts and I'm going from
microservices back towards monoliths
because it's becoming very difficult for
people to understand what's going on
Netflix gave a great quote there's many
many many blog posts out there about
this type of thing in about tracing a
Netflix said the best way to avoid
failure is to fail constantly now you
can take that in whatever way you want
but to me that actually means is that
they are testing failure and actually
injecting failure into their system
every day so they can understand what is
going on and thus this is what chaos
engineering
yes we're gonna try and get through this
pretty fast today because as I said we
all want to go and have a beer
so chaos engineering is the discipline
of experimenting on a distributed system
okay in order that experimentation gives
us confidence in the capability and it
also gives us confidence that we can
withstand production problems the best
people that test our system every day
are our users they will find a way
through your system that you did not
know existed and you will be head smack
thinking how did that bug arrive and it
does happen now you can go and you can
actually have a read on the principles
of casters very easy but if you believe
that your system does not have a
weakness one of two things is in place
one you are the best coder ever and I am
actually hiring for my team so please
come and see me at the end or number two
you have no idea what's going on in
production you don't have an
understanding or a view through to
what's going on in production and I will
probably make a rough estimate that it's
maybe 99% number two and maybe one
percent number one no there are
phenomenal coders in here
they're phenomenal coders at this
conference I'm not saying that that's
that's not the case what I'm saying is
is that sometimes we don't see
everything in production just to show
you that I practice what I preach a
little bit I thought I would actually
open up our life view of glass into our
system so you can tell me if this is of
any use or not so firstly what we have
is we have graphs for latency our whole
way through our system
this is latency changes across different
VM creates and different VM described
and so on and so forth
and we have dashboards and metrics that
do a lot of different things we collect
about 50,000 streams of metrics which
push on average if I look and have a
view in this test system so in seven
minutes
we have connect we have actually
collected four point eight million
metrics so quite a lot of metrics is
being pushed to your system second thing
we have distributed tracing for
everything we use Jaeger I would suggest
if you really like a tracing tool it's
free it's open source
there are lots and lots of other tools
I'm not saying this is the only one and
we can actually see a great distribution
of what happens through our system for
VM creates we can see actually here in
this part we had a small downtime this
is in our test system by the way this is
not our production no customers are
affected by this and I got an alert just
before I came into the talk today and
the last thing is we actually log
everything through logging this is our
debug logger that we push all metrics to
and all queries to and we can actually
see when deployments are happened and we
can see when
VM creates it happen and of course we
can actually see when logs are happening
errors are happening so understanding
what is going on in your system is
extremely important if you take nothing
away from this talk take this
you need to understand what is happening
in production it's extremely important
lost my point there and there we go so
there are different layers of our system
okay hands up full stack developers
hands up out of those full stack
developers who works in hardware who
works in network I'm joking I'm joking
I'm troll and I'm trolling as well okay
what I'm trying to suggest is is that
the job of a system isn't just within
the developer realm okay it's in the
operators realm it's in a QA realm it's
in Hardware realm to network and realm
it's everybody has to work together as a
team in order to understand the
operations of a system and because there
are layers of our system we can inject
or we can excuse me we can have chaos in
any of those areas so for example I have
been woken up many times through my last
few years of on-call where my
application is done but it's actually
not the application that's done it's a
problem in the hypervisor or it's a
problem in the network and it's actually
surface in itself in the application
layer because of late in season so on
and so forth and we didn't have the
correct monitoring in place there for
the wrong person was woken up because we
didn't have that view of glass through
the system so it can happen at any layer
really account and because there are so
many layers we can test the injection of
chaos into any of the layers so for
example let's think of network okay what
we can actually do is we can test
network latency in our system we can
inject network blocks or like the
equivalent of security group rules would
block all access to everything in Amazon
or is there if you're in there and you
can actually see how your system
responds because you're actually test
and what happens when your application
cannot talk to all the different pieces
hardware it's a bit drastic but you
could go and you could press the plug on
the server and see what happens if you
really want database you can run ACLs
and allow everybody to go in and seek
will inject your database and see how
your application reacts you can test any
of these layers please Jesus please do
not run ACLs in production and allow
people the sequel inject I will I do not
want to be sued for telling people to do
the wrong thing
here but because of all these layers and
we can inject chaos we need to know what
the principles of injecting that chaos
in you cannot just click a button and
not understand what's going on and you
can't just click a button and just throw
pieces of information to your system and
hope it's gonna be okay you need to have
a process of understanding it there are
four principles first one we define a
steady state number two we hypothesized
that the steady state will continue
number three we introduce events to
mimic what we can do in the real world
okay that that will simulate that
there's a problem or an outage and
number four we try and disprove that our
system is continually working as
expected no that's very wordy let's give
you a real-life example we often run
applications that talk to databases or
message buses or any of these things
okay so that's our steady state our
steady state is when our application is
running it is connected to our database
server great no problem we know that
that's the case because we have tools in
place that allow us to say that that's
always connected number two when the
database goes offline we predict that
the application will not be able to
function correctly great it's very
simple very easily number three we know
introduced an event that does that and
how we do that is we will introduce a
security group rule for example that
stops the application server talking to
the database server just a very simple
rule that we can put in place and we can
reverse very easily and number four we
run the experiment and watch what
happens so what do we expect to happen
the hypothesis says that when the
database goes offline that the
application should go offline if it
doesn't great brilliant you've built a
better system than you expected and
you've proved yourself wrong already if
you are correct and it does go offline
then what you can do is you can try to
plan around that failure by going into
like basic mode of your application
where you serve a front page UI that
lets users
know that your application is currently
offline you know and and you're not
throwing four or four or five or three
that's like the worst thing that you can
do for a user and that's what this does
you can break it down into its very
simplest component parts by introducing
very small experiments in that way you
do not have to go chaos monkey full
scale you really don't your applicant
your your your company will not enjoy
that straightaway I promise you but of
course we cannot do this without
monitoring we really cannot if you
cannot prove that your system is
currently stable then for goodness sake
do not try and make it unstable because
you don't know what you're going to do
when I say monitoring I mean there are
four levels of monitoring okay of course
we have system availability
that's pieces like making sure our
application server to run into hundreds
making sure that we have the correct
systems working as expected we have
system metrics making sure our CPUs or
our appropriate levels memory units
appropriate levels message throughput
through our system is as expected and
not sounder deviations above and below
because that's an anomaly that we need
to alert on number three user metrics if
you have an application that you have
users log inning or registered you want
to collect those metrics as well because
you want to know that on average day two
hundred million users log into your
application and then if the next day 50
million users log into the application
and the third day back to two hundred
million you can have got a little
problem there
you cannot need to know the seasonality
and the patterns of user metrics and
behavior through your system and the
last one which is actually the most
important service specific metrics so
for us in the cloud industry if we need
to know that the creation of a VM should
take two seconds if that goes from two
seconds on a normal day to fifteen
seconds then we have a big problem right
like I'm the per guys in Azure had this
a couple of weeks ago where they have
this
because of weather and of course they
collect these metrics and they
understand these metrics but you need to
know these metrics otherwise you have no
idea
I'm the worst thing in application
development or operations is your users
telling you there's a problem before you
can see it it's extremely embarrassing
there's an entire book about this ok we
are beyond the era of putting Nagios on
servers I'm collecting memory RAM disk
and understand them what I'm making sure
that's the only metrics we have we need
to know much more how things work for
example if your application server is
filling disk up and you just get an
alert you want to know what's the rate
of change that that disk has actually
filled is it 1% in the last month
because if so your capacity planning is
not but it's pretty bad but if it's 80%
in the last 6 hours you know that
there's a potential problem in your
system and you need to actually act on
that before it causes problems check the
book but it's very good I promise you
it'll and it'll introduce a whole new
era of monitoring into your system no
let's talk chaos engineering again chaos
engineering came out of Netflix Netflix
are like the Nirvana of DevOps companies
to work for in my opinion companies like
Netflix Etsy Google sres and so on and
so forth they've been trailblazing this
for a long time in many many years and
this actually started in 2008 ok this is
not new this is like everything in
technology we have the very early
adopters now we're having the the mass
adoption and later in another couple of
years you'll have the bigger
organizations the bigger enterprises
because they're a little slower moving
we'll be able to adopt these types of
things then it was started in 2008 and
they actually called it resiliency
testing chaos engineering is is a
newfangled term that is actually kind of
cool and it makes you want to do it who
wants to put on their CV in their resume
I'm a resilience tester
you really it's like I apologize this is
a small job it's like putting BBA on
your resume right nobody wants to be a
DBA anymore everyone wants to be a
full-stack developer a distributed
systems engineer but it's made it sexy
it's made it a little bit more oak you
know chaos that sounds a bit weird but
at the same time it has also put it in a
place where most people go sounds
dangerous if it's dangerous I can't do
it but it's not dangerous if you take it
slowly and adopt it small small small
small small and sell it then you can
actually be very successful with this
does anybody know the simian army this
is the open-source suite of tools that
netflix have created now since 2008 lots
of tools have come up okay the first was
chaos monkey I'm sure people have heard
of chaos monkey okay chaos monkey is an
instance based love tool okay
this is a tool that will act
specifically on instances specifically
on application groups or scaling groups
or if you're in Azure and there is the
same equivalent it would be like skill
sets okay it's at that level instance
management okay the next one was inside
it it's one it's important to say here
Netflix were very specifically in Amazon
so their tools were designed for Amazon
topology okay
instances sit in what's called
availability zones and there are usually
two or more availability zones in a
region okay a region would be us East
one or e u-- west one or us west two or
so on and so forth it's it's a
geographical location and inside that
there are a number of data centers that
map to be available the reasons that you
can put your systems in so what they
wanted to do is when they were confident
enough that they could test that
application servers could withstand
problems next they were like right we
really need to start testing when we
lose entire availability zone okay
and they developed something called
chaos gorilla okay because gorillas a
little bit bigger than monkey and they
can actually inject more
or chaos into the system with a gorilla
now this is really good because if
you're in the cloud you do have to plan
your architecture for the cloud so for
example if you have a database cluster
of three servers you would not put all
three servers in one availability zone
in a region because if that region goes
though and you've lost everything okay
you would plan for quorum you would put
one in each availability zone or as many
availability zones as you could and that
way you're able to withstand that only a
single availability zone origin
no I'm not saying that only ever one
availability zone goes down of course
there are disasters that happen that
take our entire data centers as the as I
said earlier about the Alps guys have to
deal with Microsoft a few weeks ago so
Netflix decided that we should test
without as well we should test for
entire regional outages and they
developed the big tool at the back
called cache calm okay and that will
actually simulate that an entire region
in Amazon goes down and that they can
fail their entire system across into
another data center this was really good
in a few instances about three years ago
there was a huge outage on us East one
in AWS anybody who knows eight of the s
knows that US East one holds I am an s3
and if you lose I am you lose a lot of
your system okay so what Netflix used to
do is they actually used to practice
failing over from one availability or
excuse me from one region to the other
and they were actually able to withstand
the outage for less than seven minutes
which is seriously impressive for the
size of organization they are and for
the size of user base that they have
they are not the only people doing this
they really are not okay
uber Dropbox Google Amazon you can read
new case studies every week of new
companies introducing this into their
system banks are now starting to
introduce into their system the the
newer bank like munzo in the UK for
example not the more traditional banks
because there are a lot bigger
organizations and it takes a lot you
know there's a lot more layers they sell
through to the top level but uber do it
due to an outage in replication of their
master logs killing their primary
database so they lost s3 so therefore
the logs actually failed to be
replicated away from their primary
database and at that point their
database server filled and filled and
filled and fill the field dropped over
okay
Dropbox did it because of master
replicas pairs in their database cluster
bringing them in the Dropbox site Google
and Amazon have been running disaster
recovery tests for longer than anyone
else they didn't even have a name for it
they just called it disaster recovery
testing like we usually have a disaster
recovery document but we've actually
tested and there are so many people
practicing this knife there really are
look at any major system outage in the
past and I can pretty much guarantee you
those teams will be trying to work out
how they can do better and how they can
avoid that from happening again I know
it's sometimes are very harsh lesson to
learn and I know sometimes it takes a
very bad event in order to make our
practices better but one bad event event
is better to be survived than five but
events you always must be trying to get
a little bit better to save your life
system failure happens every day it
really happens every day if you go
through an entire day without something
going wrong in your system as I said I
am hiring it's really important that I
get your resume because I need people
who build systems like that 99.9% of
developers it's human error we are not
robots
we are not designed that cut the most
effective code the best performant code
the most understanding of computer
algorithms in order to make it as fast
as possible okay we have to start
somewhere and we progressively get
things better and until that happens
unfortunately
system failure happens I know one of my
favorite stories of a system that I
actually broke I'm not going to say the
name of the company but again it's an
american-based company not my current
employer
it's important they say and I argued
with the CTO he put up production freeze
a week before New Year's Eve and it was
a reservation system I'm not gonna say
the name but they're in the area that I
worked in and he said we're putting the
production freeze in place for the week
before New Year's Eve I argued and
argued in our huge I said production
freezes mean you have no confidence in
your developers he was like okay let's
lift the production freeze I took the
entire system done and usually the
entire system and it was done for nine
hours now of course I had they then
explained to the CTO why I was making a
deploy in the morning of New Year's Eve
and it was my response was I'm young and
I'm stupid and I want that they show
that these processes work and he said
well it's a very important lesson to
learn you have to be pragmatic with what
you're doing and I totally understand
that line but it's only by trying to
understand what's happening in your
system can you make it better
nobody likes to be woken up at night
nobody if you do you're kind of weird
there are a lot of tools starting to
spawn from the back of this okay this is
one of them this is called a chaos
toolkit okay Carol's toolkit is an
open-source product that's on github and
it's created by a company called chaos
IQ okay and I will show you a demo of
this in practice very shortly and you
can go and have a look at what's doing
it there's a paid-for
tool called gremlin very well known I'm
sorry who used to work at Dropbox she
now works for gremlin called Tommy
Bhutto and she's there she's primary sre
and she's doing amazing things in the
Carol's community and this is like she's
really driving this product forward
which is fantastic and this will
actually inject Cass and your system and
it'll monitor everything that's there
it's like all
one product and that product has
dashboard system B and everything we've
got built in but we're gonna demo chaos
monkey okay
just cuz it's actually a fun demo
together and we'll show some stuff
anybody any questions so far no but I
just want me to show up so we can go for
beer perfect no let me show you what
I've done so just before this talk I
spun up an auto scaling group in Amazon
I'm sorry but my demos today are Amazon
specific later in the year I will be
speaking in a base conference when I
will give similar demos specifically for
Azir but I'd haven't written them yet so
I thought it's best to show the one that
I have written so I spun up an auto
scaling group with 20 instances on okay
so we're just gonna pretend that we have
a 20 instance cluster of our application
and we have a lot of users going through
it I am going to use a command line tool
on my Mac called chaos monkey CLI okay
it's an open-source product as well and
lastly I have a server that I spun up
and no you cannot login because it does
have access it doesn't have a user name
and password
and in here
I have a Gradle application which is
actually the live instance of cache
monkey okay and I can show you them and
I can show you them I can show you the
properties of it firstly let chaos run
true which is the most important thing
because we're actually going to destroy
some instances today and we want to
enable on-demand instances to be
destroyed and we don't care if anything
inside our auto scaling group is
destroyed and the probability will be
one there for every command I throw out
it will destroy an instance because
that's what we like to do and you can
start to go the whole way down through
it the most important thing is here is
you have some strategies these
strategies are extremely important
because excuse me I'm sorry
these strategies will allow you to test
different pieces of your system so the
first one is shutdown instance we want
to be able to test that when we destroy
an instance that a new instance comes
back in its place
ok second one is if there's network
problems we want to make sure our
network third one burned and CPU making
sure the system or the application can
still cope if the system CPU is like
over a hundred percent and so on and so
forth you can turn these on and off as
much as you want ok
and there's lots more there really are
you can go the whole way down now
there's a very interesting one right
here that I have my cursor on mandatory
termination ok you can actually set
chaos monkey to mandatorily kill off
each instance in your cluster in a
specific rotation ok so for example
every 32 days you want to kill all the
instances of your of your system so
it'll throw a request the 0.5
probability is 1 and every 2 will be
destroyed so you'll actually rotate the
entire cluster as you go through and you
can actually do that and check the whole
thing through now this was very
interesting for me because about 2 years
ago I worked at a startup
that funnily enough went bust as
startups do I promise it wasn't due to
what I was doing here and I used to have
an application that's called run deck ok
rum deck is an open source operations
tool and every 7 days we used to rotate
the entire cluster of servers and
destroy them one at a time so at any one
point in time our servers were only
seven days old now it's you're probably
thinking what's the point you know what
is actually the issue there firstly we
introduced security patches at a maximum
frequency of seven days which was pretty
nice
secondly we destroyed any manual
tinkering on the boxes every seven days
because developers are weird developers
like to touch things developers like to
go into boxes and SSH and remote desktop
and I'm toggle that on or change this
setting only because of the fact that if
they go through the operations theme
it'll take two weeks so what do we do we
access agent and we change it and then
our application works
we are weird people we don't follow
rules we are not robots so therefore you
can actually get this system and it will
run over your entire system day by day
by day by day by day and the interesting
thing is the guy who wrote this tool
this person right here he actually has a
blog post about this that he runs this
right now I can't remember the name of
the company he works for but they have a
H a proxy configuration over the front
of their chaos monkey instance and they
can just log in and actually see what's
going on and it's just running publicly
against their production server every
day and I find that fast name that he
blogged about that because that is a big
security risk I'm telling people that
you actually have a chaos monkey
endpoint in place anyway so there's a
lot of interest in things that you can
do with this and as I said this is very
specific for Amazon there are tools
available for Xero look at some of the
things that's available and the last
thing is is that you can send
notifications maybe you don't care when
chaos happens in your system maybe you
really don't maybe you're so
far down the line that your system is so
resilient that if an instance dice you
don't care about you you trust that as
your or Amazon will replace that
instance and you trust that your
application will recover as expect it
and it will bring it back into the loop
and it will serve requests but when
you're getting started you probably want
to know what experiments have happened
no in a last talk I gave someone said
can we set a schedule for chaos just
think about that for a second can we set
a schedule for chaos and it was a fair
question because it was it was their
first foray into chaos testing and they
wanted to do it
outside of normal workers and I sort of
suggest that that's not really chaos
testing at that point that's just going
back to leg straight resilience test and
our application based testing but it got
me thinking you can set time periods for
this I am NOT going to say that that's a
bad idea if you set a time period
because it will take you some time to
get up and running with this it will
take you some time to sell it to people
within your organization because it
really will you tell your CTO or your
boss or your my line manager that you're
going to destroy a production server 50%
of the requests that you make to chaos
monkey every day he's gonna go or she's
gonna go Nana no no no we do that
intestine or in the QA environment so
it's maybe good to set some rules and
some boundaries about when things happen
and it's also maybe good to show some
notifications that it has happened for
two reasons one it will introduce a
little bit more confidence that an event
has triggered and look the system didn't
fall over okay or to an event has
happened
the system has fallen over because it
will it will ultimately be the case
so let's actually run some chaos I told
you I have this tool so cash monkey will
look at what's configured in my chaos
environment right now and it will show
me
today that that I cannot connect
anything oh if I actually put the
correct port oh wow okay and you can see
I've actually been running tests this
afternoon
I thought it would be kind of
professional if I tested my demo a
little bit and not have a failure that I
just tried it out right now
and it's like a very simple trigger a
burn CPU trigger a fairly c2 nothing
crazy okay so I thought let's look at
what's going on in the system and let's
run the following command ok hit my
chaos endpoint this is a publicly
accessible endpoint please do not make a
request on your behalf on my behalf if
you have a laptop right in front it may
destroy my demo okay so I'm gonna talk
to the auto scaling group PF ASG I
specifically made it difficult because
somebody did try and attack my chaos
monkey endpoint during a talk so I'm
gonna try my best and not let that
happen okay and the strategy I'm going
to use is I'm going to shut down the
instance and I'm going to run that
command ten times at an interval of 60
seconds between each come on okay so I
can now make the hypothesis that ten
machines will be destroyed in a ten
minute period and Amazon will replace
them to bring it back the system back to
20 so let's just run that in the
background and we'll see first ones
shutdown or excuse me the first one is
test is underway and if i refresh i
should see the first application is
shutting down right there and if i go
back to my chaos endpoint if it'll give
me the log i put in a second because the
process is run on the background then I
can tell the logs to find out what's
going on it will tell me the instance is
shut down new one spawn up in its place
and it's keeping it more importantly now
if I go back and if I chaos
I go to the endpoint
you'll see a new one just happened at
time zones are crazy for me this one
right here 8:15 in the morning in London
or in just excuse me UTC so we can see a
new one has happened in its place and a
shell bone is an instance right now and
in 60 seconds just because that's how my
auto scaling group is set up Allison
will start bringing a new one up look
there's a new one shutting down so my
system is like starting to be under
pressure first instance is dying what's
going on second instance is starting to
go down it's like wait Amazon hasn't
brought any new ones up yet and if I go
into my auto scaling group Amazon's
gonna tell me should tell me very
shortly that there are some problems
with instances and it will show me the
life cycle of some instances is starting
to be affected so it is gonna happen in
the background it takes I think my
service configured for a min excuse me
and it'll start to replace them in the
background let's just go and see if it's
gonna spend any up it not quite yet
so we can let that run in the background
and see what's going on my let's have a
look at the open source tool okay
as I said chaos monkey specifically for
Amazon so let's look at something a
little bit more agnostic
platform-agnostic to show actually
what's going on and let's have a look at
like a tool that's designed specifically
to fit the principles of chaos okay so
the first one is terminate the database
master should not prevent the
application from running exactly what I
told you the example was okay
description is there steady state
hypothesis is currently all systems are
available and healthy database cluster
is up application cluster is up health
endpoints are work in status endpoints
are work and everything's returning
normal amounts okay we are going to
terminate the DB master we're going to
probe that the DB master is actually
going through and we're still going to
probe at the end that the application
server will continue running
okay now it looks weird and if i refresh
we will see let's run the experiment
terminate the DB instance we validate it
everything is currently looking good the
system is running as expected let's wait
for a while the application or the the
DB master is being terminated let's wait
for 20 seconds why let's actually go on
offline shut them down draining
connections etc as soon as this happens
very shortly I promise
come on 20 seconds it's waiting oh there
we go
probin we're still fetching database
logs lastly we're checking that the
application is healthy and alive and
then we're actually getting a pasta say
everything is working and that
experiment can run run run run run run
run and run and run every day we run
every week every year whatever term
whatever period that you want it to
actually run for it's written in Python
but it's not specifically for Amazon
it's not specifically for Xero it's not
specifically for GCP and so on and so
forth
now there are current drivers in place
for these tools and if I go to the
drivers browse the extensions we can see
there are kubernetes it's so popular
right now like people are building this
in from the start
Amazon there are M points that people
building for Amazon there is this you're
Cerebus fabric which is awesome to see a
zero starting to come in here and the
open source word for the the chaos
endpoints because I know there were some
things internally for them I don't who
meal which is the application we use
things to do with Cloud Foundry GC
Google cloud engine activities
Prometheus activities there are lots and
lots of drivers it's open source you can
take it you can write your own drivers
your own extensions and you can start to
run your own experiments and it doesn't
have to be terminating your database it
can be as simple as terminating a
security group rule
okay or adding a new security group rule
making sure your system can still work
as expected okay it can even be lower
level than that fill your database your
database EBS driver your EBS volume and
that way that your system can still
still work second one cut off the
security group that ships your logs from
your local desk to your log server okay
you can start really small and you can
start to really understand what's going
on in your system let's go back to
Amazon and find out what's going on here
so we can see two servers are currently
destroyed and we can see that there are
still a placate this is an application
server that's currently being replaced
in its place we can see this one's an
application server that's being replaced
so the experiment is running the
experiment that's going through and it's
killing our applications servers and
it's bringing them back up and we can go
and have a look at how many it's done so
currently it's done seven instances and
it'll just keep going through and
through and through and through and
through now if you want to not cheat and
destroy every instance then there is
another command that you can run this
one is slightly different ok so again
we're going to attack the same auto
scaling group we're gonna run it five
times in a period of 10 seconds and the
probability of a destruction event is
actually only 0.2 so 10% succeeding 10%
20% okay so one and only one out of our
entire cluster in this case will
actually fail or excuse me will actually
be destroyed so therefore this is a much
less risky experiment to run the last
one I'm running a probability of one so
you can start to tinker around with
what's actually going on and how many
times a day chaos monkey is running or
whatever tool that you choose in order
to understand what's going on in your
system any questions no one care it's
just a quiet room perfect
No excuse me there are lots of resources
okay so the first one I showed you is
principles of chaos okay
there is a whole community around this
there's a slack organization okay
there's lots of very good community
curated information as well lots of
github repositories that you could go
and visit you can see and then the last
one of course is you can go and visit
how a simian army works in order to try
to understand what's going on in your
system to try and implement those
practices there is also of course like
every good technology a conference
around it
unfortunately the conference is next
week okay so it's gonna be unless you're
in America it's gonna be pretty
difficult to get there next week but
there are some amazing people running
keynote so like for example Adrian
Cockcroft who now works at Amazon or
yeah AWS and who used to run engineer at
Netflix and was one of the four fronting
peoples of how to do this okay also
Jesse Frizzell who works at Microsoft
who is the queen of you know container
security and understanding about chaos
of containers and stuff like that there
are a lot of people who are going to
engage with this ecosystem in this
community in order to drive the best out
of what you're actually doing and
understanding what's going on more
importantly sharing is actually given
other people ideas about how to test
within your environment it's very
difficult to go away sit in a room with
other people who don't have any
experience in this area and try and
design chaos experiments you must be
speaking to people you might I'm not
specifically saying you have to go to
conferences design for it but you must
be speaking to people who have
experience in this area who have
designed these things with mind and in
mind okay just this morning I was
working before early while I had a call
and I was actually job and buying some
chaos experiments that I was thinking
about for what we're building we're
building them a new vm create piece and
I'm thinking how can we actually build
an API that's an internal API that we
have a tool that just runs every
all day in every single time and one of
the tools I can actually show you that
we had done so we want the test that our
our cloud is actually able to you know I
showed you the metrics this the the
these metrics right here of how we're
able to see that all the VM creates are
actually happening and that they're
happening within this specific amount of
time so what I thought it would be quite
good to do this is not open-source I'm
afraid but we have an application which
we call VM canary vm canary and so it's
a little application that just runs and
it runs in concurrency levels and it's
running inside our we have we used an
application scheduler called no Matt so
this is always running it's always
firing VM creates as soon as it runs our
create it runs a select it runs an
update and it runs our destroy but it
runs parallel requests at the same time
we can fine tune it again I thought it
would be interesting to show you how we
actually configure this and fine tune it
no my job's VM canary so we can have
back off periods we can have concurrency
levels we can do all the different
pieces that we actually need so we are
building tools into our system as we are
designing this new feature that will
test resiliency of our system of course
I'm working in a greenfield app and it's
all very nice and very easy for me to
start building that in and some of you
are sitting out there going well I'm
working on a 15 year old application
that's like a million lines of code okay
you can start this is like I'm not
comparing it to these things it's like
when you started continuous integration
for that project or continuous delivery
for that project or added all these
monitors or you were starting to do
DevOps for that project you must start
small start at the very smallest
component this piece that is not is
going to cause least concern and use
that small piece in order to grow
confidence when
within the system next time you have a
hack day for example spend two hours or
three hours or an interesting couple
lawyers actually trying to design a care
system for your environment for your
test environment start with non
production don't go for a production
start with please please but you can
really start to do it and you can
actually start to leverage some tools
it's very simple so for example you have
a very simple CLI up that you run as a
service or a batch job and all it's
doing is firing a delete request at your
API that's a simple chaos test it's as
simple as it gets you haven't needed to
use or buy a tool you've written
something in a very short period of time
and you're actually getting immediate
confidence in your system and you're
getting an immediate value add for your
system because that's ultimately that's
what we want to be into the pay we want
to add things on that creates value for
our customers to let our customers know
that we're trying to do the best things
for them a great example would be and I
only said because I'm in Australia and
remember Troy hunt
Troy is one of these people who finds a
big by way of social media and so on all
of these different systems that don't
have SSL Certificates for example right
and it's there are lots of them right
there wouldn't it be really good if you
could run a chaos experiment that
actually changed your certificates okay
in your test environment again not your
proxy environment that change the
validity of your certificates or
actually like deployed the wrong
certificate change the key is
certificate because certificate
management is a problem it's not
something that's easy to do in different
platforms and we do make mistakes so
again we have so Comus inside
and we actually have a rule set that
checks for certificate end dates and
checks for certificate errors so we can
actually start to mess around with
certificates we use ansible for
certificate management in this way so we
can run an answerable command but deploy
is the wrong certificate that our test
server our monitoring system should pick
that up
straight away and alert that that's the
case so we should be able to straight
away there are hypotheses there is that
we should get an alert we should have a
severity one because it does affect
customers and does affect security
so therefore the remediation is we need
to fix it straightaway and that must
happen within an SLA time and if it's in
the middle of the night somebody must be
woken up so it's very simple experiments
like that okay and you must start off
with monitoring monitoring and metrics
are the most important part and I can
show you this exact metric integrations
checks just give me one second these
metrics are firing right now we can see
certificate end in seconds it is
actually there the value just hasn't
been calculated in fact let's look at
the metric we can see the certificate
and certificate end in seconds is like
1.5 million or something like that
so we have an alert in place that says
when the certificate is within seven
days
send severity two if no one has and
actually fixed up that certificate if
it's at six days and all their severity
- if it gets the three days send the
severity one if it gets the one day
alert the entire Engineer and part of
the organisation because it's really
important it's really to understand when
certificates are a problem when
certificates are in issue so we're
starting to build our own caste test in
from the start the one piece of advice I
give you join the Kaos community
it's a slack organization if you use
slack there are lots of useful people in
there who you can talk to who do this at
scale really at scale and you can tweet
me if you have any other questions thank
you so much your time and enjoy the boat
cruise tonight if you're going
[Applause]